talkshow minister karl lauterbach der
wird jetzt echt ein minister halb
deutschland freut sich halb deutschland
regt sich darüber auf aber was macht den
aktuell berühmten teil deutschlands
eigentlich aus und das wollen wir uns
jetzt mal gemeinsam genauer anschauen
den kosmos nämlich und dafür nehme ich
euch nämlich sie mit rüber an unseren
touch wir haben einmal in diesen kosmos
geblickt von karl lauterbach 58 jahre
alt geboren in düren und 1 meter 82 groß
ja was genau macht seinen kosmos aus und
hier sehen wir schon ein paar bilder die
sich um ihn herum versammeln man fragt
sich was hat ihr zahlst ein auto und ein
junges mädchen das wir nicht kennen mit
karl lauterbach zu tun da helfe ihnen
jetzt ein bisschen auf die sprünge salz
spielt im leben von karl lauterbach
unserem zukünftigen gesundheits mir das
überhaupt keine rolle mehr denn er
verzichtet darauf bereits schon seit dem
jahr
1989 komplett auf salz denn er sagt das
macht demenz also wenn er mal bei ihnen
zum essen eingeladen ist verzichten sie
auf salz es hat einen kleinen roten
smart ein bescheidenes auto für einen
politiker der jedoch auch schon öfter
einem jahr zielscheibe von attacken auf
ihn gewordene gewesen ist wo ich hab ne
beschissene wurde denn er ist und bleibt
eben auch einer der umstrittensten
politiker in unserem land karl
lauterbach mit vollen namen carl wilhelm
lauterbach hat fünf kinder von zwei
frauen
sein privatleben hält er auch privat
hier sehen wir aber ein seltenes foto
von ihm und seiner tochter rosi jetzt 14
jahre alt das also ein kleiner
ausschnitt aus dem kosmos dieses mann
ist der unser gesundheitsminister sein
wird und darüber freut sich halb
deutschland sehr und halb deutschland
gar nicht und damit zurück an kein
schreiben jetzt dem berühmtesten karl
deutschlands mal die erste to-do-liste
bevor er also dann den stab offenbar
offiziell übernimmt von jens spahn wir
wollen wissen was muss er als
allererstes anpacken der karl lauterbach
und das wollen wir mal klären mit dem
hausarzt unseres vertrauens mit dem bild
hausarzt sozusagen mit thomas mann der
uns zugeschaltete schönen guten morgen
herr hausmann
grüß gott aus der maschine versorgung
des enkels schöne grüße nach berlin ganz
kurz einmal nur emotional freuen sie
sich weil karl lauterbach spaltet ja
nach wie vor das land das zeigt auch
unsere bild umfrage von gestern 50 50
etwa 50 prozent freuen sich 50 prozent
ärgern sich zu welcher seite gehören sie
also ich freue mich natürlich darüber
dass jemand mit fachkompetenz da ist
gibt er den spruch erfahren sie politik
oder jemand der ahnung hat also von
daher kann man mal karl lauterbach
bestimmt sagen er hat ahnung und macht
politik und von da können wir hoffen
dass er zumindest die pandemie den griff
kriegt und annehmen kann man sich auch
reiben deswegen weil der positionen
vertritt ob die mal richtig sind und so
weiter das ist ja was anders aber er hat
zumindest eine haltung und das ist
wichtig bei dann kann man auch sagen mit
in eine diskussion treten und sich dann
austauschen das tolle ist ja dass der
mann diskutiert das haben wir hier auch
bei bild immer erlebt selbst wenn wir
völlig anderer meinung waren er hat sich
gestellt und wir konnten diese
diskussion hier ganz offen austragen das
hat immer große freude gebracht und wir
hoffen dass genau das so bleibt aber
jetzt wollen wir ihnen die to-do-liste
schreiben gemeinsam mit ihnen herr
doktor erstmal also was muss drauf was
muss der karl als erstes anpacken drei
punkte erster punkt an die medien regen
dazu bedeutet genügend impfstoff
besorgen das bedeutet dass eventuell
eine impfpflicht kommt damit wir
wirklich auf 90% impfquote kommen und
eine struktur schaffen dass wir im
nächsten jahr die impfungen hinkriegen
weil so wie es aussieht müssen wir etwa
80 millionen impfungen nächstes jahr
machen und da müssen wir wirklich eine
gemeinsame großtat machen dass wir das
auch alles hinkriegen das zweite ist
dass wir die auch ärztliche versorgung
überhaupt in deutschland stärken zum
beispiel bekamen jetzt wieder in
nordrhein-westfalen regresse von den
krankenkassen gekriegt sie werden es
kaum glauben wichtig wegen impfungen ja
und das dritte ist dass wir miteinander
reden können die kommunikation
miteinander verbessern das heißt nicht
nur immer im gesundheitsministerium die
reichen und die schönen und vielleicht
auch die meisten leute aus maschinen
rauben gehört werden weil die wissen
nämlich wo der schuh drückt und damit
meine ich ganz konkret dass auch die
hausärzte bei entscheidungen
in an bord genommen werden und
rechtzeitig miteinander gesprochen wird
also drei dinge braucht der minister
spreche mir das thema impfen noch mal an
es ist ja jetzt ganz konkret die größte
herausforderungen die vor dem
gesundheitsminister liegt was muss da
ganz konkret passieren damit es
vorangeht dann hat er das gefühl das
thema impfen es wird uns noch eine ganz
lange zeit begleiten sie wissen ja nach
der vierten welle ist vor der fünften
welle und wir müssen ganz klar sagen es
muss sichergestellt werden dass wir den
impfstoff den wir auch bestellen auch an
kaufen und zwar in der menge die wir
noch brauchen das ist das erste
das zweite ist bis der impfstoff
möglichst irgendwann vereinzelt werden
kann bei einzeln bedeutet dass wir denen
nicht mehr mühselig anmischen müssen und
dann wirklich lange wartelisten haben
und zwar der sondern einfach neben der
sprecher nebenher verhelfen können das
ist eine einzige spitze möglich und dann
das dritte dass wir in der infrastruktur
schaffen das wir stellen schaffen dass
wir wie gesagt im nächsten jahr auch
wirklich die 80 bis 90 millionen
impfungen auch für image bekommen das
ist ganz ganz wichtig und dann
vielleicht noch das allerwichtigste dass
für eine große impfkampagne machen dass
die leute bitte freiwillig wenn es sich
impfen lassen weil wir haben das problem
von den 2 300 impfungen die mir in den
letzten 14 tagen gemacht haben waren
leider nur fünf bis sechs erstimpfungen
zur frage ja oder nein herr doktor us
machen gehen sie davon aus dass der
berühmteste carl deutschlands in seiner
amtszeit in seinen vier jahren corona
besiegt haben wird am ende
also
ich glaube dass herr lauterbach schon
sehr viel kann und ich glaube dass karl
supermann das hat vieles schafft aber
wir gemeinsam können nur die pandemie
bekämpfen lauterbach es bestimmt eine
der führenden position die das
unterstützen kann aber damit meine ich
das wirklich ganz konkret wir alle
können die pandemie bekämpfen aber auch
nur wir alle können sie dann noch
besiegen das heißt wir alle müssen uns
impfen lassen dann können wir die
pandemie besiegen und kein einzelner
alleine sondern jeder zusammen wie
können schaffen
aufmunternde worte noch mal von doktor
als wenn vielen herzlichen dank ihnen
für das gespräch und wir wollen gleich
jemanden zu holen der sicherlich auch
hohe erwartungen an karl lauterbach hat
uns war rené wachtmeister es
intensivpflege häusliche intensivpflege
schön dass sie bei uns sind welche
erwartungen stellen sie ganz konkret an
den zukünftigen gesundheitsminister
ja wir morgen
ja ich denke er muss das alles auch in
dieser tour irgendwann einfach eine
spindel und ich finde das eine sehr
momentan der coach
das bild was ist dienstlich was da ist
zwar dass die plus da ist mit mit
testers ohne dass er sollte da schon
bündeln können und
egal was er tut in seinem amt ich
schätze ihn auch dass er viel erfahrung
hat und ja kurz danach gehen wir vom
fach ist das was er tut auch gut
begründen kann und man ihm mehr
vertrauen schenken er glaubt als
vielleicht manch andere ersten er ist
ein fachmann und das ist das was wir
gebraucht haben das leben in diesem amt
im koalitionsvertrag steht ganz konkret
drin dass pfleger und pflegerinnen mehr
geld bekommen sollen
aus ihrer ganz persönlichen sicht wo
würden sie sagen fängt für sie ein lohn
ein gehalt an bei dem sie sagen wird
okay das ist für meine arbeit angemessen
das ist so schwer
zu machen
ich denke so
motto
können wir mal anfangen zu starten
konkrete zahl der karl lauterbach
hoffentlich hört um dann das auch
umzusetzen müssten koalitionsvertrag
steht herr wachtmeister vielen
herzlichen danke ihnen für das gespräch
wir wünschen